DRUGS AS WELL.
>> CASEY STEGALL IN TEXAS.
TO THE NATIONAL CONTROL COUNCIL
PRESIDENT.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU TODAY.
LET ME GET YOUR TAKE, BRENNAN,
WHAT CASEY WAS REPORTING.
NUMBERS OF SURGING, RECORD
NUMBERS, HOW LONG DOES THIS GO
ON?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, LET ME GET
TO THAT, BUT TO KEEP IN
CONTEXT, YOU SEE SOME FLORIDA
FLAGS BEHIND ME, I'M IN FLORIDA
RIGHT NOW WITH CONGRESSWOMAN
KAMIK, DOING A GOOD JOB TO
BRING ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE,
I'M FROM THE SOUTHWEST BORDER,
IT SHOWS THAT EVERY BORDER IS A
BORDER STATE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS AND WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW, AS THE
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO INCREASE,
WE CONTINUE TO GET OVERWHELMED
WITH EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE TO
DO WITH WHEN WE'RE PROCESSING
THOSE ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS
AND WHAT THAT DOES, THAT ALLOWS
THE DRUGS TO FLOW INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S WHAT'S COMING UP TO
FLORIDA, MAINE, IOWA, NEBRASKA
AND THAT'S WHAT'S KILLING SO
MANY OF OUR U.S. CITIZENS.
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO GET
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION UNDER
CONTROL.
IF WE CAN DO THAT, THEN WE CAN
GO AFTER THE CARTELS AND
PROFITS AND DANGEROUS THINGS
COMING INTO THE UNITED STATES
WHICH INCLUDES CRIMINAL ALIENS,
ALIENS FROM SPECIAL INTEREST
COUNTRIES, ALL THE THINGS THAT
WANT TO DO HARM HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, BUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE PROPER POLICY TO DO IT
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT GETTING
THE POLICY NOR ARE WE GETTING
THE PROGRAMS OR OPERATIONS.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, BRAN DAN, WE
HAD A GUEST IN THE LAST HOUR,
MANY ARE ARRIVING IN NEW YORK
CITY, FIVE, SIX BUSES FILLED
THIS PAST WEEKEND ARRIVING AT
THE NEW YORK PORT NORTH AND
OFTEN TIMES, THOSE PEOPLE GET
OFF THE BUS AND THEY CAN GO
WHEREVER THEY WANT.
THEY'RE GIVEN A SLIP OF PAPER
FOR A RETURN COURT DATE AND ALL
OF THAT.
WHERE THEY GO AND NO ONE IS
TRACKING THEM AND I'M
WONDERING, THIS ONE PARTICULAR
GUEST WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY HAVE TO
THEN PAY BACK SOME OF THE
CARTELS THAT MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN
THEM ACROSS THE BORDER IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
AND THAT HEIGHTENS THE DANGER
AND WE KNOW SOME OF THEM ARE
DOING SOMEONE ELSE'S BIDDING
AND IT'S NOT GOOD BIDDING.
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY, THEY HAVE TO
PAY BACK THE CARTELS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
INDIVIDUALS COMING OFF THE BUS,
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DO NOT HAVE
$6,000 IN THEIR POCKETS TO GIVE
TO THE CARTELS UPFRONT.
AND DEPENDING WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM, IF YOU'RE COMING
FROM CHINA UPWARDS OF 35 TO
$50,000.
I MAKE A VERY GOOD LIVING AND I
DON'T HAVE THAT JUST SITTING
AROUND TO GIVE CARTELS AND
THESE INDIVIDUALS DO NOT
EITHER.
THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING INTO
INDENTURED SERVITUDE TO PAY
BACK THE CARTELS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR YOUNG WOMEN
AND CHILDREN, THAT OFTEN TIMES
MEANS THE SEX TRADE THAT IS
VERY DANGEROUS FOR THEM AND
IT'S FRUSTRATING TO ALL OF US.
WE WANT TO PROTECT THE SANCTITY
OF LIFE.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE FREE TO MAKE
PROPER CHOICES, BUT WHEN
THEY'RE INDEBTED TO THE
CARTELS, THEY HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PAY THEM
BACK BECAUSE THEIR FAMILIES
BACK IN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES
RELY ON THAT.
IF THEY DON'T PAY IT BACK, THE
FAMILIES END UP PAYING FOR IT
AND THAT'S THE SERIOUS DANGER
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE SO
FRUSTRATED RIGHT NOW.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE THAT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS THEY'RE PUTTING
VULNERABLE WOMEN AND CHILDREN
IN HARM'S WAY WITH THEIR
RECLESS POLICIES.
WHEN YOU HAVE OPEN BORDER
POLICIES, WHEN I'M BY THAT, THE
REWARD, WHEN WE CATCH AND
RELEASE THEM ETHAT'S THE REWARD
AND THE OPEN BORDER POLICY,
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT ALL YOU'RE
DOING IS ENDANGERING HUMAN LIFE
AND THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
NEIL: INCLUDING THE PEOPLE THAT
GOT OVER THE BORDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRANDON JUDD.
AGAIN, WE ARE SHOWING A LIVE
SHOT OF THE